[music] the
beginning of the shooting and here I
felt that like this,
on top of the Christmas tree, the shells began. I would have it
ticking right here, I got bored in the store
and there I was waiting for an ambulance, I was
bleeding,
and there were growing up, it seemed here at school
there once was and  like this I shot and
here it
seems that the explosion was there the explosion was in tadesh
here The anchor of the explosive mat from no
explosion here the fragments just fragments
went off here I shot and here oh
Near here
[music]
I don’t know I won’t say Why I won’t
say the whole roof  beaten flows no one
helps me in any way
[music]
I am for peace in general for all
of us because all our
relatives brothers and sisters live there, so of
course we worry about everyone, I have
relatives of Ivandeevka and therefore
we were also there  shelling is why they are in
Donetsk We are worried about everyone We are for
peaceful residences and therefore we only want
peace
[music]